[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el 28 de
junio se cumplieron en colombia 2 meses
de movilizaciones las ong de paz y
temblores hicieron un informe sobre las
cifras de violencia en el marco del paro
nacional para hablar de este balance nos
acompaña a camilo gonzález posso él es
presidente del instituto de estudios
para el desarrollo y la paz indepaz
además magister en economía y ex
ministro de estado gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 cuántos
casos documentados de violencia policial
durante estas protestas y cuáles son los
casos más graves
un buen día pues el registro que se ha
hecho que es parcial e indica más de
3500 acciones agresivas violencia
policial
digamos que van en exceso de fuerza en
contra de manifestantes una situación
que por supuesto ha tenido consecuencias
muy graves han identificado 49
situaciones de muerte de manifestantes o
de personas que estaban cerca de las
manifestaciones sobre presunta
responsabilidad de agentes de la policía
y de cerca de 80 jóvenes que han tenido
lesiones en los ojos mujeres abusadas es
una situación de exceso de uso de la
fuerza en medio de la protesta también
detenciones arbitrarias con desaparición
transitoria de unas pelotas muy
prolongadas de manifestantes tenemos
todavía que sin explicación el
procedimiento utilizado para la
detención en secreto de 700 personas de
las cuales 150 están aún desaparecidas
ha aparecido muertos de modo que es una
situación muy grave
camilo se toca a un punto muy importante
y es que qué papel entonces juegan estas
desapariciones en el contexto de la
represión policial ustedes las vinculan
también con la violencia paraestatal le
pregunto por qué
sí sí porque no solamente actúa la
fuerza pública la policía del esmad sino
también civiles con armas el civiles o
policías de civil que no tienen una
identidad una identificación clara es
decir que hay un comportamiento para
policial paramilitar de ciudadanos que
en colombia pues había una tradición de
paramilitarismo muy larga
se activan este tipo de problema mental
y da de sí procedimientos de modo que es
muy peligroso porque se han presentado
en cinco regiones de colombia 5 ciudades
pero esta historia de violencia
económica es tan crítica que si eso no
se frena de manera categórica voy a
activar una obra de paramilitarismo
urbano sin precedentes ahora qué tipo de
justicia y reparación espera que se haga
con las víctimas o en el caso de los
fallecidos con su familia así como
influye que los miembros de la fuerza
pública sean procesados por la justicia
militar
pues lo primero es que debe haber un
reconocimiento en la acción del estado
de responsabilidad y no una
victimización porque el gobierno está
utilizando una expresión genérica es el
vandalismo y una justificación tácita de
que la acción de fuerza y los disparos
ustedes son resultados del vandalismo ya
sea por fuego cruzado de los mismos
manifestantes o por acción justificada
de la policía porque se presentan cifras
y fibras de situaciones de violencia
contra la policía situaciones que se han
dado y son condenables pero no son
asociables a estas situaciones lo
primero es la no estigmatización que
opere la justicia realmente y sobre todo
que exista un replanteamiento que se
suspenda el uso de esta maquinaria de
guerra urbana que el gobierno ha montado
con la fuerza disponible y con la
asistencia militar urbana ahora cómo
puede afectar entonces todo lo que
estaba ocurriendo en colombia con sus
relaciones internacionales de hecho
congresistas estadounidenses han pedido
suspender la ayuda directa a la policía
colombiana
pues la verdad es que la imagen del
gobierno colombiano a la luz de la
comunidad internacional es de un
gobierno con una las características
dictatoriales en el manejo de la
propuesta y digamos que hay tiranía
frente a los derechos de manifestación y
protesta en colombia y la comunidad
internacional está alerta haciendo
advertencias e incluso en el congreso de
los eeuu en el anunciado suspensión y en
el parlamento europeo y re parlamento y
también la suspensión de cooperación y
apoyo a la fuerza pública en colombia
hasta tanto no exista una clara
rectificación el desprestigio del
gobierno es muy grande y ese discurso de
guerra el gobierno en el diciendo que
todo lo que pasa es que hay un
terrorismo de baja intensidad una
revolución molecular grupos armados en
las ciudades es una exageración una
estigmatización de nuevo y eso es yo
creo que es un motivo de gran
desprestigio para el gobierno colombiano
en la comunidad internacional camilo
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en francés
un feliz día de ustedes gracias por
acompañarnos siempre en 5 minutos con
[Música]